As you go through this course, you might encounter commands that
you've never seen before. And we don't expect you to know everything,
but we do want you to keep the following in mind
when you encounter any sort of challenges or difficulties. First, take an
active role in problem solving and be aware of the resources
at your disposal. You can type a question mark and the name
of any function to bring up help documentation in R. So
for example I can look up the documentation for the function mean.
Here it will tell me any parameters that mean takes. And
it will give me examples usually at the bottom of the documentation.
I can copy and paste these into the console. And press
enter to see what the function does. Here, I created something called
x, and then if I hit x into the console, I
can see what this is. This is just the vector of numbers
zero to ten, and then the number 50. I can take
the mean of x, and print it out. And finally, I have
some sort of trim parameter. Maybe you can figure
out what this does. Now, if you can't solve your
problem using the documentation I would suggest Googling it.
StackOverflow is also another great site to browser for help.
I've linked to some of the most useful websites
in the instructor notes, and you can also find these
in the course materials under Our Resources. One of my
personal favorites when I learned R was Quick-R, or statmethods.net.
This site has excellent examples and short pieces of code that
can refresh your memory and get you going on any data analysis.